One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. Hello. Hi there.
Okay. We have some really exciting news today. next adventure. Hello! Hi there! Okay, we have some really exciting news to share. We do, Jenna, tell them. All right, my husband Lee Kirk is directing a movie called New Year's Rev and me and Angela both have parts in it. We do, I'm so excited! Tell them what it's about. Okay, well this is a story that he wrote with Billy Joe Armstrong of Green Day, because you know Billy Joe starred in Lee's movie Ordinary World.
That's right. And they stayed friends all these years. His family is very good friends with our family. You know that this delights me. I know, you're very tickled by it. I am. And so the two of them came up with this story and then Lee wrote the script.
He's now directing it. Here's what it's about. It's about three high school kids who get pranked into believing that their punk band was picked to open for Green Day on New Year's Eve in Hollywood. Yes. And so they take this crazy road trip across the country.
Yes, all the while believing that when they eventually get to LA, they're opening for Green Day. And of course, a bunch of crazy stuff happens on the road. And some of the stuff that happens on the road is based on stuff that actually happened to Green Day during their years of living in a tour van. The movie stars Mason Thames and McKenna Grace, along with a whole bunch of other folks like me and Angela.
It also stars Fred Armisen, Sean Gunn, and Bobby Lee. The movie features a ton of Green Day music and ends with a Green Day concert. Unfortunately, me and Angela don't have any scenes together, but we both have such fun roles. Yeah. So, you know, we got to do this table read. And I mean, how much fun was that table read, lady? So fun. I can't wait for people to see the movie. Jenna, tell them who you play.
OK, I'm playing Jodie. She's the mother of Tommy, who's played by Mason Thames. And she's a widowed mom who's doing her best to get by and support her family. She's a waitress. She has kind of like a rock and roll past and she's just trying to do the right thing by her kids. Right. Well, I am playing Wilma and I just love that my character has that name
because my mom had a sister named Wilma who I love dearly. Your Aunt Wilma. My Aunt Wilma from Mississippi. Well, this Wilma is a loud and kind of a foul-mouthed proprietor of a rough-and-tumble Road House in the middle of Oklahoma. Y'all I was born to play this role. You? I know this woman. I know her. I have met her. I'm telling you I'm thinking about like in
my hometown there's a Legion Hall. Yeah. Where you can go have an adult beverage. I know, I know her. Well, it is such a great, fun part. You are gonna shine. I can't wait for people to see you in this. And can I spoiler alert? Angela, you have been growing out your roots for this role. That is how committed you are. I am, I am.
You have not been coloring your hair because- For a month, y'all. Look at me, I'm like, y'all, for a month. I just felt like Wilma probably wouldn't fuss with her hair. She's busy, she's running a bar. Yeah, she is. Yeah, but I do think she gets her nails done. I haven't shared that with you yet.
Oh, okay. I do. Yeah. Because in my family, the Southern gals, they never miss their nail appointment. Everything else might be falling apart, but their nails are done. Yeah, I like. Yeah. Because in my family, the Southern gals, they never miss their nail appointment. Everything else might be falling apart, but their nails are done. Yeah.
I like this choice. Yeah. Well, we had a big conversation. Does my character have a tattoo? Because of her past. Oh. And I said, she definitely has a tattoo. I think the question is,
is her tattoo in a place you can see it? Oh. Because it could be somewhere that you wouldn't see I think the question is, is her tattoo in a place you can see it? Oh. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Because it could be somewhere that you wouldn't see while she's just at home having coffee. What did you decide? She has several in places that you can see and not see. Oh. So there you go.
That's what we went with. Okay. All right. So we're sharing this with you because we are off this week. We are shooting the movie. We're in Oklahoma. We are. So today we wanted to bring you something
that truly helped both of us so much as we kicked off 2025. Yes, it is Kendra Adachi, AKA The Lazy Genius. It's episode 399 titled, It's a New Year. Let's name what's working. Yeah, so for some context, as 2024 was wrapping up, Ange and I sat down and we talked about what do we want for the new year for office ladies? You know, this is that time of year where you
Reflect. You reflect. You set goals. That's right. And we both had some of the same shared goals for how we wanted our podcast workflow to go. And we were in this sort of reevaluating mindset. And then on January 1st, this episode of Kendra's dropped and I listened to it and I immediately
texted Ange about it. I was like, this is what we're doing. Angela, I need you to hear Kendra's approach to this conversation that we had already started, but she frames it in such a delicious way. I know. Kendra is so good at this. She offers up such an accessible way
to think about what is working for you, which in turn makes you see areas that could use some attention. She has three rules, three questions, and three categories to help you ask yourself what's working in your life? And lady, I loved that. I loved coming from a place of positivity rather than negativity.
And now our office ladies team keeps using this phrase, what's working? What is working? Yes, this has totally crept into our conversations during our team meetings. And using this, we have created new strategies to manage our workload, we've created new routines, it has been great.
And we're using it at work, but it really can apply to every aspect of your life. So to relationships or maybe just even the rooms in your house. After I listened to this episode, I walked through my house and I would look at a room and be like, what's working here? Yeah. And that simple question helped me appreciate this little caddy that I bought to hold pins and pencils and scissors. It was just like
in that little nook in my kitchen where all the random clutter goes to pile up. Yeah. Well guess what it's not piled up anymore it's in a little caddy and it's working for me and that small thing makes me happy. I love that. But that's just such a small little thing but when you look around and see what's working it makes you want to do it to the other rooms of your house. It's like this wonderful domino effect or to your relationships or to your workflow. It's like okay well this one thing is working how can I make the rest of it work for me as well? Yes so So I have to eat a pretty specific diet because
of the cancer medicines that I'm taking. I have to eat like high protein, lots of fruits and vegetables, high fiber, low sugar. In fact, if I don't eat this diet, sometimes I don't feel well. Like it has a direct impact on how I feel in the day. And I was getting really overwhelmed with meal prep. Like mentally. Like mentally figuring out how
every meal was gonna fit into this very specific box was exhausting. But I did not have the luxury of being lazy about this. Right. I had to do it. So I used her philosophy. I asked myself to look at each meal from the framework of what was already working. Because in the moment, it felt like nothing was working. Right. But actually, when I looked at it, my breakfast is working. It's easy.
I eat the same thing every day. It's great. My dinners were working because I was already planning and prepping family meals that pretty much met my criteria. So really, the only thing that wasn't working was my lunch. And Kendra suggests that you ask yourself if you can apply what is working about one routine to your routine that is not working.
So when I dug deeper, I was like, well, why is breakfast working? And it's pretty much because I eat the same thing and I don't care. I don't care that I eat the same breakfast. So I tried to apply that to my lunches. I picked three lunches that I could prepare easily, quickly, and that I could make in batches of like three to four days worth. So my three lunches now are soup, chili, or tuna salad. Done.
They have all the stuff in them that I'm supposed to eat. And now I'm not making a new lunch every single day. And you're not stressed about it. No, and it's working. Now all three of my meals are working. That's great. I know. It's such a simple question.
And I think that's why it's so easy to act on. Yes. Well we hope you love this episode as much as we did. It's just such a great way to start the new year. And just know we are having a good time in Oklahoma. We can't wait to tell you about it. Exactly. But now here is the Lazy Genius episode. It's a new year. Let's name what's working. Hey there, you're listening to the Lazy Genius podcast. I'm Kendra Adachi and I'm here to help you be a genius about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. Today is episode 399. It's a new year. Let's name what's working. Today is the first Monday of January, which might
feel any number of ways for you, but just in case you have scattered, oh no, Today is the first Monday of January which might feel any number of ways for you but just in case you have scattered oh no it's the first Monday of January energy or if you need a reminder that you don't have to chase greatness at the gate this episode is for you. The beginning of the year or the beginning of anything often has us rethinking our routines and rhythms and systems and choices to see if there's anything we want to change. That path is well and good and likely necessary on occasion. I love identifying small problems, applying small solutions, adjusting over time, and then slowly building rhythms and systems that work from those small decisions. It's a slower go compared to big black trash bag energy
where you just start everything over, but it lasts longer because you don't keep starting everything over. So before you start to put on your problem-solving glasses, utilizing that new year January energy to make everything fresh and ready to begin, let's name what's working. Okay. I have three rules, three questions, and three categories to help you think this through. You can take whatever helps and just leave the rest. You can be as detailed as you want and write stuff down, or you can just think about it in your head, decide that this particular thing is working really well,
high five yourself and move on. You use the content in this episode in whatever combination and intensity you want. So three rules, three questions, three categories. Let's start with the three rules. Rule number one, when you're naming what's working, the smaller the better. Naming small things that are working in your life are weirdly powerful. You might try and say breakfast is working pretty well, but the specificity and smallness of having muffins in the freezer and protein yogurt drinks in the fridge are working super well for everybody.
The smaller the thing, the greater the opportunity for you to truly understand what is working. You can see the particular moving parts of the thing rather than just like a large ambiguous category. So rule number one, the smaller, the better. Rule number two, when you're naming what's working, working doesn't mean perfect. We're naming what's working. We're not naming what's perfect. Very little is and very little will be. Perfect is relative and arbitrary anyway. So as you assess and decide what's working in your life, be kind about that word. Working doesn't mean and decide what's working in your life, be kind about that word.
Working doesn't mean perfect. It's working. It might be a little janky and how it's working, but it's working. Don't be so hard on yourself. Rule number three, when you're naming what's working, now isn't forever. What's working now might not and likely won't work forever. That can swing both ways. You can have something you love that's working now might not and likely won't work forever. That can swing both ways. You can have something you love that's working now. And also it's good to remember that we have to hold these things with an open hand. It might not work forever,
but we'll enjoy it now while it does. Or if you do have something that's working, but it's connected to something in your season of life that's frustrating to you and you wish it were different. That's okay. Now isn't forever. It probably won't always be this way. So try not to resent where you are.
Either way, now isn't forever. So those are your three rules as you move into naming what's working. The smaller, the better. Working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. With that perspective in mind, let's move to the three questions you can ask to help you narrow your focus on what specifically is working in the categories that we'll name in a minute. The three questions are, what problem does this solve? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? First, what problem does this solve?
When you're looking at an area of your life and you're identifying what's working there, naming the solved problem could be super beneficial. You know, maybe it's solving a problem that you've had for a long time and naming that the problem is solved is worth celebrating. Maybe it's solving a problem that you're spotting in other places. So seeing the success of your solution in one place, it might help you get ideas for another place. Essentially, like what problem does this thing that's working solve for you. We have a drink spinner on our counter. It's just a wooden
lazy Susan on the edge of our kitchen island. And I put it there years ago to try and solve the small problem of glasses and water bottles being all over the house. Kids would leave bottles and cups on random surfaces. They'd be in different places in the kitchen, which made the kitchen feel visually cluttered. It was a small problem, but an annoying one. So I thought that a great way to maybe solve this small problem would be with a small solution of one place where the cups and water bottles go. They have a holding pen and unless they're being used, that's where they live altogether. It's like one big beverage family. The drink spinner works beautifully now. It took a while for kids to remember, but it has become second nature to everyone in our house. Your cups
and water bottles, they live on the drink spinner. End of story. If I walked into my kitchen and I noticed that drink spinner as I'm, as I'm looking at my life and being like, you know what, what's working? Let's celebrate what's working. I would say this is working because it's all the problem of keeping track of cups, but also of my silent rage about seeing cups everywhere. Let's say I have silent rage about something else that seems to live all over the house. Noticing how the drink spinner is working
helps me recognize a small solution for a separate small problem. So as you're identifying what's working, that's the first specific question to help you see why it does. What problem does this solve? This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about like the red flags to look for in a relationship.
But what if, what if we like changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners? You know, like more like instead of framing it, here's what I'm avoiding, be like, here's what I want to run toward. OK. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know, BetterHelp is fully online,
making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. You can access a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies.
What happens when fear and prejudice are ignited by the hysteria of war? I'm Sharon McMing, host of Here's Where It Gets Interesting. I answer that question in my new series, 9066, and dig into the stories of more than 120,000 people of Japanese ancestry who were imprisoned in the United States during World War II. Find here's where it gets interesting in the free Odyssey app and everywhere you get your podcasts. Before we get into the second question, let me remind you again that you don't have to be precious or orderly or organized with these questions.
You don't even have to try to answer any of them. They're more for those of you who need a little clarity and trying to identify what's working. And we do this anyway because we care about today. We care about who we are right now in this life we live in. We care about remembering that we do actually have things in life that are working. We can find our way out of early January discouragement of all we wanna change.
Instead, we're gonna name what's working. So use these questions if they help. All right, the second question you might ask is, what do I like about this? Let's keep joy and pleasure and ease in mind here. What do you like about this thing that's working? Taking a lunch break every day works so well for me because it solves the problem of not always slowing down on purpose. What do I like about it? Well, I like food. So there's that. It's nice that it's lunchtime. But I also like that there are no
expectations for me for that lunch hour that I take. I can eat and watch a show or eat and read a book or eat and sit on my porch and silence for a few minutes before going inside to watch a show or read a book. I like that I can do what I need to do in the moment. But whatever I choose is genuinely enjoyable to me. Name what you like about a thing that's working. Put some meat on its bones as to why. It gives it more staying power and personal enjoyment that way.
Remember, perspective really matters here. And a third question you might ask to help you understand what's working is, how does this make me feel like myself? Not everything might, and that's fine. But in order to slowly nurture an integrated life that is rooted in your own humanity and what matters most to you in your season, it's not a ridiculous thing to consider how your decisions and rhythms
and systems make you feel like yourself. You might say this thing makes me feel calm, which keeps me from going outside of myself in a rage. This thing makes me feel creative, even though I'm doing something mundane, because I'm doing it in a unique way that's working for me. You see what I mean? Also, a lot of you often ask me how to figure out
what makes you feel like yourself. Sometimes I think we put too much pressure on that question or on the feeling. When something makes you feel like yourself? Sometimes I think we put too much pressure on that question or on the feeling. When something makes you feel like yourself, it might not be the most happy fulfilled unicorns and rainbows version of yourself. You might feel like yourself because of the house rule, no piles on the kitchen island. Visual clutter might take you out of yourself. So visual tidiness, especially in commonly used spaces like the kitchen, makes you feel more out of yourself. So visual tidiness, especially in commonly used spaces like the kitchen, makes you feel more connected to yourself. It
doesn't have to be technicolor to count. So three questions that could help give a little insight into why something is working are what problem is this solving? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? Now you might be ready to start naming this in your life, but you might feel a little scattershot about it. You know, you're a pinball within the machine of your life, just like freely associating what's working as one idea pings into another.
And that's honestly a great way to do it. This does not have to be a detailed homework assignment. It's ultimately, it's just a posture. Just name what's working. Look for what's working. Don't focus so hard on what's not. So ping away. If you want to ping, ping.
Now if you'd like to be a bit more methodical or if you would enjoy a new way of looking at the areas in your life so you don't miss anything even though you totally well. Here are three categories that you could consider time of day, regular events and rooms in your house. Now these are broad on purpose. There's simply doors you can walk through to kind of help you notice and narrow your focus on what you would like to notice. So category one, the time of day, all right. Mornings mid morning. If you're home with tiny humans after school, transitioning from work to home, dinner, bedtime routine, evenings, et cetera, et cetera. Start your thinking at one time of day and just look around.
You can even live in it like tomorrow morning. Pay attention to what's working. What do you see that solving a problem? What do you see that you like? What do you see that makes you feel like yourself or make someone else in your home feel like themselves? Being present at a certain time of day or using your imagination and memory for that particular time of day, it can help you notice what's working. Category two, regular events. What tasks or events or activities happen on a regular basis? Meals. Meals are very regular. Carpool or commuting, regular meetings, decide once gatherings like messaging friends while you're waiting for your groceries to be loaded into your car or like actually going grocery shopping with a friend every Tuesday or whatever it is. Look on your calendar if you use one or just pay attention to the regular things
in life and notice what's working in there. And then category three is rooms in your house or rooms in your life. Different rooms have different functions. So literally walking into a room in your home, it can help you notice what's working there. There could be decorating decisions or cozy decisions that make you very happy. Maybe you think of tasks that are often done in that particular room. You know, what about cleaning that specific room? Walk into a room in your house, pause, and ask yourself, what's working in here? What happens in here that's working? What do I like about this room?
What do I like about what happens in this room? These can be physical rooms in your own home, but they can also be like your car or your desk at work or any physical space you spend time in. What's working here? So those are the three rules, three questions and three categories. The three rules are the smaller the better,
working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. When you're naming what's working, keep those three things in mind. The three questions that might help you identify why something is working are what problem is this solving? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? And then the three categories
that could help you narrow your focus are times of day, regular events, and rooms in your home and life. So what do you do now? The point of these ideas is not to fix things. In fact, it's the opposite. We are noticing what's working so that we stop the spin out of thinking that everything isn't. This time of year has us in our heads about fresh starts and big changes. And again, while those are totally fine, begin where you are. Begin with what's working. Celebrate it. Notice it. So often when we see how many things might be working,
we calm down a little about what isn't. So even though you could, in theory, go through your entire life with the three rules in mind and ask all three of those questions, I don't think that's necessary. That's not starting small anyway. Pay attention to the area of your life that has the biggest pull for you to make it better. Stay in that place and instead name what's working. Be where you are. Be kind about the things already in place. Refresh your perspective on the things in your life that do in fact solve your problems. Things that you like that make you feel like yourself. Be who you are and where you are today. You're
doing great. If you'd like a peek into what's working for me on a really practical level, episode 349 is called 10 Small Changes I'm Glad I Made. And then episode 366 is 20 Helpful Decisions I Keep Repeating. Those are practical, practical lists of what's working in my life, and many of them have been working for years. The tiny solutions, the small changes, the decisions you make once that still work, those are the parts of a steady system that you don't have to keep starting over on. So be where you are. Notice what's happening today. Celebrate the changes you've made.
The smaller, the better. Working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. That's how we start a new year. Let's name what's working. One thing I know a lot of you do at the end of December and the beginning of January is to reread the Lazy Genius way. I mentioned that last week. I love that y'all do that. It's something that works for you and it's humbling and fun for me. So thank you.
Having a refresher on the 13 lazy genius principles as you're going into a new year, it really is helpful. If you have never read my first book, The Lazy Genius Way, it dedicates a chapter to each of the 13 lazy genius principles. Decide once, start small, ask the magic question, live in the season, build the right routines, set house rules, put everything in its place, let people in, batch it, essentialize, go in the right order, and be kind to yourself. It's the Little Engine That Could book, just plugging along, still selling copies over four years later. If you've never read it, but you have thought about it, now is a really
good time to do it. I read the audiobook so if that's more your speed to listen as you're like taking down holiday decorations or going for wintry walks or trying to keep your children entertained before school goes back, give it a shot. I think you'll enjoy it. This is also an excellent time of year to read the plan. It's all about compassionate time management, helping you rewire your thinking from optimization and greatness and making the most out of your time to just being a grounded whole person right where you are. Being okay with some things being great and others just being mid. It's practical,
permission-giving and full of pep talks to get you through any January chaos you might experience. I read that audiobook too. But I think for the plan, you'll be so glad you have the physical copy. So thanks for reading my books and supporting my work y'all. It means a lot. Okay, before we go, let's celebrate the lazy genius of the week. This week, it's Ashley Eidsen
with a super interesting approach to holiday gift giving that actually matters a little right now at the beginning of the year. Ashley writes every year, my husband and I save up our credit card rewards across a few different cards and we don't spend them all year. Then when it is Christmas time, the amount we have in rewards is our budget. We know how many gifts we need to buy each year.
We know how much we have and that's how we divide it up. Some years we've had to make some decisions like not getting gifts for every coworker in the office, but it always seems to work out where the people we wanna give gifts to comes very close to our total. Last year we had a little bit higher rewards total and we were able to buy some presents for ourselves
at the end of the year on top of everything else we purchased. Hope this helps someone else enjoy the holiday season without stressing about breaking the bank with the regular monthly bills and expenses. What a fantastic idea this is. Can you see why I wanted to share this one like right now at the start of the year? This could be a fantastic approach for a lot of us when it comes to holiday budgets. The rewards just do it for you. Love how practical and helpful this is. So thank you for sharing Ashley and congratulations on being the lazy genius of the week. This episode is hosted by me, Kendra Adachi, an executive produced by
Kendra Adachi, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. The lazy genius podcast is enthusiastically part of the office ladies network. Special thanks to Leah Jarvis for weekly production. Thanks y'all for listening and until next time, be a genius about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. I'm Kendra and I'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.